cbs news elections and surveys director
anthony salvanto is here with what we
can learn from the record-breaking early
voting numbers
anthony good morning to you 82 million
that's the estimated number of people
who have voted early
what does that tell us about enthusiasm
and how can we read into
overall turnout based on what we see so
far
hey good morning tony that 82 million
that you mentioned
is a record and i think it's a mixture
of enthusiasm
and also anxiety voters tell us they
think this election is the most
important of their lives
but they're also worried about voting in
a pandemic trying to get those ballots
cast in time i think based on this
that our turnout is going to go to a
record 150 million
maybe higher than that but there's still
some mystery in here
and it's going to be this tony already
democrats tell us
that they've cast more early ballots
than republicans and our analysis both
of the polls
and the voting registration rules
supports that so democrats have
what you might call a lead right now but
what's remaining still out there
leans more republican so the question as
we head into election day is going to be
do republicans turn out in large enough
numbers to catch up
they have the numbers to do it does
democratic turnout slow down and if it
does
the republicans can catch and pass them
and that's going to be the big setup
for november 3rd tony so national
presidential elections are state by
state affairs which is why we talk about
a path to victory
what are the paths to victory for the
two candidates and
are are there potential upsets on the
map as you see it
yeah there are potential upsets and a
lot of surprising
swing states this year tony some of them
we've talked about
in the sun belt for one example a lot of
people are looking at arizona our
polling there has that
as a toss-up joe biden would love to
flip that
hasn't gone democratic since the 90s
well
for the president though he's going to
try to
replicate his 2016 map i think he's
going to try to
win florida always a battleground win
georgia which is a toss-up
and then he's got to go to the upper
midwest and win
back ohio pull a couple of these lean
blue lean democratic states in the upper
midwest
maybe wisconsin out of the democratic
column
maybe try to pull off a surprise in
minnesota as well
so the president goes to the upper
midwest joe biden needs to hang on
to what he's already got as a lead up
there tony so anthony
some states under state law will not
begin processing and counting mail-in
ballots until election day
itself what will that mean for how early
in the evening or into the next day
you'll be able to give us results of
this election
i suspect i will have a very late night
as will everybody
but we'll stay with it i want to show
you specifically how we do this though
let me
give you an example out of michigan for
uh for instance
we know that a state breaks down into
heavily republican areas
and traditionally heavily democratic
areas well
if the ballots haven't been counted yet
let's say i'll use the
upper peninsula of michigan and northern
michigan as an example
that's republican area if the ballots
haven't been counted there yet i'll tell
you it's a republican area that's still
out
here in detroit that's a democratic area
if
their ballots haven't been counted yet
we'll tell you that there's probably a
big
number of democratic ballots still to
come so we'll give you that complete
picture at cbs news from the decision
desk
and then you'll see a comprehensive view
of what's in
and what's out and we'll show it all to
you such a valuable picture
into what you guys do you've been doing
it at the cbs news polling unit for more
than 50 years the country's relied on
you
to make those calls and we will rely on
you again on tuesday
anthony thank you very much we
appreciate it